peuple
[Musique]
vacances le voici arrivé le moment tant
attendu
on va partir on est partis départ
soigneusement méticuleusement organisé
départ aussi vouée à la plus haute
improvisation est au bout du chemin on
va enfin voir se profiler le coin
tranquille dont on a rêvé toute une
année les rayons du soleil sont
excellents pour l'organisme mais il faut
en user progressivement et avec mesure
n'essayez pas de faire disparaître trop
vite votre belle couleur aspirine
d'hommes blancs
les brûlures graves peuvent laisser des
cicatrices pour toute la vie une
exposition trop prolongée au soleil peut
entraîner des désordres sérieux dans
l'organisme
attention aussi aux surfaces surchauffée
houphouet de l'exercice vous bougerez
mais n'exagérez pas non plus ne forcez
pas comme disent les sportifs de trop
longues marches à pied ne sont pas la
formule à appliquer aux vacances
[Musique]
mordu de navigation sous marine ne jouez
pas au scaphandrier avec un matériel
insuffisant et il existe mille façons de
se faire remarquer sachez choisir
si vous campez ne vous croyez pas pour
autant obligé de démonter et de remonter
votre tante tous les jours sous prétexte
de changer de coin le camping vous offre
c'est entendu une mobilité très grande
mais ne confondez pas camping et
mouvement perpétuel
vouloir évaluer ses vacances au nombre
de kilomètres parcourus au nombre
d'hôtels habité quitté l'ain pour
s'installer dans l'autre n'est pas non
plus une manière idéale de profiter de
ses vacances
d'autant que vous pourriez passer
certaines nuits dans des conditions de
confort plus que contestable
[Musique]